I wanted to make pieces that seem as if
they were moving or living as if you
know there were
really breathing
my work it's so many things it's joyful
it's pop it's craft it's the rock it's
decadent
this is King Style
my name is King tinku and I'm a ceramic
artist
foreign
[Music]
Paris is is my base is the lab
[Music]
there is a long wall in my studio that
has a lot of images on it and these
images represent things that influence
me or bits of the history of Ceramics or
the music that I like or the type of
pieces that I like and so on and if you
had to print out my brain you would get
that wall
that's where I can just write whatever I
feel
it's as confusing as my brain works
[Music]
as soon as I have an idea I can draw it
and then I'll
look at the drawings play with the
colors
and next step is choosing the right type
of clay to make the type of workout that
I want to do
thank you
then I wedge the clay that enables you
to take off all the air bubbles in the
clay and prepare the clay
and then once the clay is well prepared
and ready to be worked on I
get on the Wheel
and that's when I start throwing the
basic shapes that will make the base of
my artwork
[Music]
foreign
to make a piece it might take me
three weeks to two months roughly
but
it's more complicated than that because
I work on so many pieces at the time you
know I work on 20 pieces at the time
so while some pieces are drying I'm
working on another piece and then wow
some glazes are drying I'm you know on
another piece so
it's never one piece
[Music]
in 2012 I went to visit a friend in
Tokyo and we went out one night and I
met this Japanese girl who told me about
pottery
[Music]
and at the time also I was sort of like
soul-searching like I was already
involved in a career in Communications
but I knew that my creativity could
serve better causes
and
um she told me about it and somehow that
word Pottery stayed in my mind and it
kept coming back coming back coming back
and when I came back to Paris I found
this Japanese Workshop Pottery Workshop
where I could start Pottery for the
first time
[Music]
and
once I touched clay it's almost as if
like sleeping thoughts awakened and
that's when you know things changed for
me
it's almost as if you feel
like there's sort of like electricity
coming from your hands throughout your
whole body and it awakens something that
seed inside and then
you
questioned your whole life again
I trained between Paris and Bizen in
Japan and Bizen is one of the six
ancestral
CD for pottery in Japan
there I was able to connect with
toshiaki shibuta who became a sort of
like Pottery father
him and his friends taught me the
kikuneri technique the spiral wedging
technique
it's sort of like Prince and the Clay's
memory the circular movements
and so it's easier for you to throw
he taught me so many things
um for example throwing slowly on the
wheel and taking your time while you
throw you don't have to throw fast
and let the clay absorb each of your
movements and you know
be slow with it be gentle with it
my friends in Japan taught me so many
things about their culture first of all
but also
you know about life because I lost my
dad very early on like when I was
eight nine so somehow through Ceramics I
sort of like found you know other
fathers and you know Big Brothers uh
that could teach me things
[Music]
we are very different
it's a different generation different
lifestyle
um different skin color
but we connect thanks to the clay and
for me that type of relationship is gold
at the beginning I was only making
functional pieces
and because I looked up to my Japanese
pottery fathers I wanted to be like them
but they also made me realize that no I
I cannot be like them and I should be me
that's when I started to make more
sculptural pieces
and realize that yes my energy wasn't a
polar energy it was more of an artist
energy someone that wants to create
different things and not make the same
thing over and over again
[Music]
when I was younger I used to be bullied
like
a lot and were sort of like not accepted
by by other peers and I was able to find
like security and peace in video games
and virtual world
where I could control the character
where I could choose the character I
want to be and and go on an adventure
games like Zelda or
[Music]
um Metal Gear Solid
it's so amazing to be able to pull these
Concepts and grow these Concepts that
you know you grew up with that you had
in your childhood and like drive them
with you into your adulthood and bring a
message out of it I
then was able to dig deeper in who I am
where I come from my roots
um from West Africa and Benin with the
spirituality and so on
when I train in Bizen I sense
spirituality and the way that my friends
were making their works
and that spirituality is highly infused
by the culture of Shinto and that made
me realize that that spirituality was
very similar to the one of voodoo in
Benin in West Africa and both religion
or a system of beliefs they share the
roots of animism and
there was this I don't know like the the
it resonated in me it also feeds you
know me as a maker
um in my studio when I create my work
because I use Clays from different
countries from both countries too
I don't have an academic background in
arts so I just use my intuition to put
colors together
but I have sort of like developed my own
theory about
the way I use color and one of them one
of the theories is that
for my work it's
80 percent
texture and 20 percent
pigment
um
and that's that's how I work so what
really brings life and gives life to the
color or the piece really is the texture
[Music]
working with the four elements Earth
fire air and water is amazing because
these elements are older than us human
beings and I truly believe that these
elements know more than we do it's
almost as if I'm asking questions about
my future and I'm Consulting the clay to
gain knowledge out of it
[Music]
I've had people asking me if it tears my
heart to you know apart from work or you
know just sell or work and see a piece
leave the studio and I'm like no like
the whole adventure of thinking of the
piece and then making it and having it
out there
um is the whole fun for me then what
comes at the end of that process is a
byproduct of the whole Adventure
foreign